aliens
I don't find - these things are like
World War Z zombies
it's good there guys like you to help
the world
tech support you really did it this time
seriously yeah you asked for my help
and then we end up up the Greek heroes
vs. aliens the four night crossover
event starts with Supergirl Monday
November 28th on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie you'll never
guess how Barry messed up this time
so crossover footage let's break it down
so we finally get a look at the
dominators they like a combination of
prosthesis and a little bit of special
effects but mostly practical effects so
you guys can let me know what you think
of a when they were initially talking
about them I just had no idea what they
would actually look like on screen but
they actually look pretty good it's like
something out of a John Carpenter movie
you know it's like slime just poured all
over it but the thing is is we see the
flash like investigating this wreckage
here now obviously the flash is like the
first night of the crossover even though
they're going to address it on Supergirl
it's just that they said that Barry will
have to go get Cara bring her back to
earth one to help out with the threat
but we don't really know how that's
gonna manifest but really like their
innate power is just their incredible
intellect like they're a race of
geniuses with a lot of really awesome
toys so we'll see how they try to
subjugate the earth and how close they
stick to the comic book plot this is all
from the invasion comic book storyline
that was written by Todd McFarlane the
guy that wrote the spawn comic so this
is all back from the 90s so it's a big
deep cut but as with all big comic book
plots they kind of do their own version
of it just because the invasion
storyline in the comics was for like all
of DC's titles it was kind of like a
secret Wars raices on Infinite Earths
you know kind of involved all their
titles all their heroes and they can't
quite do that on TV because there are a
couple key characters that are missing
so it's basically gonna be like a big
for our action set piece movie like
something that they could put in a movie
theater if they wanted which I'm
surprised they didn't they actually did
that the first year arrow and flash did
the crossover they aired the episode in
like a big movie theater but that does
make you wonder if they're doing
something this big like a big four-way
cross over this year how they're gonna
try and top that next year they'll
probably pick some other big huge comic
book arc we can talk about that after
the episodes there and that's gonna be
in two weeks so just a reminder about
that not next week but the week after
that
but the whole thing is is gonna be you
know what brings the dominators to earth
does it have anything to do with them
shooting that beam of information out
into the multiverse trying to look for
another Harrison wells and we actually
see the new Harrison wells from Earth 19
here meaning that they'll probably hold
off on Jessie quick
or to Harrison wells till after the four
night crossover maybe midseason finale
or maybe episode 10 but for the most
part as far as I know all the main
characters will be involved in the
crossover last year they left a bunch of
people out like I don't think that iris
was in the crossover we hadn't really
met Wally that much yet so there were
just a lot of people they didn't have on
the flash and obviously Supergirl was on
another network they actually started
calling her erth erth CBS so like you
have earth one earth to earth 19 earth
CBS but what about Deathstroke though
this is probably one of my favorite
moments in the trailer when he just
whips his sword out just like surprise
that's gonna be one of the
craziest episodes because it's arrows
100th episode so they just took the
opportunity to do everything they ever
wanted to do so I'll be interested to
see how they try to shoehorn that in
logically like either there's a
mind-control element but like we see
Laurel and the pictures here so it's
like okay how do you explain Laurel
being back if she's still dead in
present day so there's just a whole
bunch of craziness that I wouldn't worry
too much about until the crossover
starts but I expect when they show up
like they'll tee up big concepts that'll
give you an idea for how they're gonna
proceed each night but obviously the
last night legends of tomorrow will be
like the resolution of that so that's
probably where this scene comes from
like they kind of demarcate this footage
with different characters hanging out
together like the legends are hanging
out together in a scene then you have
Barry and Oliver and I see I can't
believe you messed up this big like
flashpoint was a big deal but this time
you really messed up so I'm just really
excited that they even decided to try
this like a TV network crossing show's
over isn't a big thing like people
crossover all the time but this is
taking it to the next level like slowly
comic book TV has started to evolve both
Marvel and DC like we have Ghost Rider
on agents of shield big a-list
characters Marvel is doing a Black Bolt
Inhumans TV show on ABC next year which
I'll talk about tomorrow but it's just
getting crazier and crazier
so naturally the DC shows also doing the
same thing so I think that because the
dominators showed up during a legion of
super-heroes story they're doing ma Nell
on Supergirl
we will eventually see them do a legion
of super-heroes story on one of these
shows probably Supergirl just because
they do so much space-based stuff but
let me know what you guys think of the
footage
and what do you think they would do for
next year's crossover I think it's still
a little early to do crisis on Infinite
Earths there's still a bunch of big
things they could do like war world
would be really cool bit like Mongol
trying to invade the earth would be
another cool crossover like they called
this trailer heroes vs. aliens
we could do heroes versus war world a be
really badass but just a reminder the
Tuesday night there is a new episode of
the flash so be sure to subscribe to get
that and there's a new round of the
giveaway so all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video so the DC giveaway
will run all week it's just a $20 Amazon
gift card so I'll just remind everyone
when I post that flash video tomorrow
you know I will do that Marvel Inhumans
TV show video tomorrow before I post my
flash video while you guys wait for that
episode you can click here for tonight's
flash trailer and you can click here for
my Westworld Theory video thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight